ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
welt und meine lieben freunde ich hoffe
ihr bleibt heute bis zum ende des videos
dran denn ich habe mir noch nie vor
einer episode minecraft mit lucca so
viele notizen aufgeschrieben
ja die habe ich wirklich bitter nötig
denn ihr wird bereits im titel
eingeblendet
ja
mein mund ist einigermaßen wieder
verheilt ihr seht bereits im titel
eingeblendet meine lieben freunde denn
wir kümmern uns heute um die village
insel
und wir werden die upgraden auf die
willicher insel 2.0 da meiner ansicht
nach allerdings bauen immer das
langweiligste einer voll gemeinschaft
mit luca ist würde ich sagen fahren wir
als erstes mal da ganz hinten wieder zu
unserer villiger insel und holen uns
einen neuen villiger weil der der hier
war der es irgendwie nicht mehr da bevor
wir das allerdings tun könnt ihr mir mal
ganz kurz in die kommentare schreiben ob
ihr hier
eine brücke seht ich hab da ja gerade
sonnenweg mit seerosen blättern aber ihr
könnt mir mal unten in die kommentare
schreiben ob ich da eventuell in einer
der nächsten folgen eine brücke hin
bauen soll
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon bei dem
wasser dorf hier vorne angekommen ihr
seht schon hier vorne das schaf wartet
immer noch auf mich die sache ist
allerdings dass wir das schaf auf jeden
fall holen werden sobald ich die tier
insel angehen werde also dann werden wir
das schaf auf jeden fall holen ich weiß
ich habe ich hier vorne noch was drin
habe was ich gebrauchen könnte für heute
das hier und das nehme ich mit ich kann
theoretisch sogar einfach mal alles
mitnehmen weil ich jetzt ja gerade auch
den platz habe und dann können wir auch
die kiste jemand mit abbauen die sache
ist was sich nämlich auch noch von hier
brauche ist die glocke das womöglich und
in die kommentare geschrieben und zwar
ist es eigentlich ganz geil weil dann
kann ich die mitnehmen und immer wenn
ich zeit
perfekt immer wenn ich diese glocke dann
an berühre glocken läuten immer wenn ich
eine glocke läute dann wissen die
willicher hey wir müssen uns zu unseren
betten bewegen und das ist eigentlich
ganz gut um die dann mal so ein bisschen
auf trab zu halten wo sind denn hier
will just jetzt einfach mal hier vorne
hin hier sind auf jeden fall ein paar
villiger mehr und ich glaube dass ich
ihn einfach easy hier einschieben kann
so dass er sich jetzt daran setzt genau
wir haben den willicher drin wir haben
die glocke mit am start und noch mal
ganz kurz details wie ich zurück zu
meiner insel fahren
so da sind wir wieder hier vorne
angekommen ich halt mal direkt hier
vorne an und geh ins den schlafen denn
ich habe keinen bock
ich habe keinen bock dass irgendwelche
zombies ankommen und unsere winter
wieder töten wir haben ja auch allein
schon vier oder fünfmal dorfbewohner aus
dem wasser dorf hinten geholt und die
sind alle verschwunden ich werde mich
jetzt allerdings auf jeden fall bevor
ich den winter hier raus lassen auf die
insel packe darum kümmern dass wir eine
vernünftige umgebung für die hier erst
mal schaffen von daher ganz kurze
teilnimmt wie ich erstmal eine menge
erde abbaue
[Musik]
so ich habe hier gerade wirklich zehn
minuten lang also einen kompletten
minecraft tag lang abgebaut ihr seht
schon die ganze erde insel hier ist
ziemlich zerrupft die sache ist
allerdings sie benötigen das ganze
einfach weil ich meine insel da hinten
also diese widder insel rechts
eingeblendet seht im bild einfach mal so
ein bisschen unter erden möchte ich weiß
nicht das richtige wort dafür ist
allerdings ist es ja oft so gewesen dass
wir irgendwie ein blog abgebaut haben
dann sind wir runter gefallen waren
direkt unter wasser dann sind die
village am rand nicht richtig hoch
gekommen weil die blöcken ja einen höher
sind und man kleine glocke im wasser hat
also das wollte ich so ein bisschen
anpassen auf jeden fall werden wir von
bot
sie doch entspannt aus broich beiden
damen ich würde allerdings sagen dass
ich mich jetzt ganz kurz hier vorne
wieder hinstelle den willicher einmal
ganz kurz darin lassen
[Musik]
das ist ein hausboot daran kannst du
schlapp ist
mir auch egal ich die hier vornherein
auf jeden fall und werde mich kurz
hinlegen und euch dann jetzt tatsächlich
nochmal eine time labs einblenden wie
ich meine komplette erde nehme und die
komplette insel hier endlich mal
vernünftig unter erde
so ich habe gerade wirklich acht oder
neun stacks erde in einem dreiviertel
minecraft tag hier komplett verbaut ich
habe die insel auch mal ein bisschen
erweitert denn wir brauchen wirklich
eine menge platz fahren ist was wir
heute machen wollen und hier unten ist
nun
[Musik]
geht runter ist nun alles unter erdet
worden und wir haben nun hier eine insel
die wirklich sich auch insel nennen kann
wenn ich jetzt den bock abbau ist nicht
mehr so dass man jetzt ins wasser
reinfeldt sondern man befindet sich noch
auf der insel und wenn ihnen welche
village runterfallen von der insel
können sie auch hierüber jetzt ganz easy
einfach wieder darauf klettern und das
habe ich überall rings um die insel
herum gemacht dass sie auf jeden fall
schon mal deutlich besser aus
dementsprechend da die sonne allerdings
schon fast untergeht würde ich euch
jetzt erst mal ganz kurz zeigen was ich
heute alles vorhabe denn ich möchte auf
jeden fall diesen baum hier vorne
abfällen denn wir brauchen wirklich eine
menge platz für alles was ich heute
bauen möchte ich habe total bock auf die
heutige episode denn ich habe mir
wirklich noch nie und das beginnt schon
gesagt so viele notizen gemacht ich
möchte diesen kompletten bambus jahr
abbauen denn den benötigen wir wirklich
eigentlich absolut überhaupt nicht der
einzige grund warum ein bambus in
minecraft braucht das entweder wenn man
irgendwas damit bauen will da ist man
bisher noch nicht so richtig eingefallen
oder wenn man irgendwas mit solchen
halterungen machen möchte also
irgendwelche hohen bauwerk und dann kann
man darüber hoch und runterklettern das
haben wir allerdings auch erst mal nicht
vor ich werde auch hier vorne die farm
abbauen da fragt euch jetzt auch
wahrscheinlich luca zufolge ist sie mit
dem baum und somit der farben ja die
wird ja auch bleiben sagte es allerdings
dass die farm einen blog höher werden
soll also ich möchte die so ein bisschen
angeben so dass sie nie
warum gebe ich mir eigentlich die mühe
für euch ja ich möchte die farben auf
jeden fall einen blog höher machen damit
die hier so richtig schön stattfinden
kann und ich möchte den weg ja auch so
ein bisschen weiter fortführen denn wir
werden ja auch noch ein neues häuschen
heute hin bauen wir werden hier und hier
einen neuen brunnen stellen die vorne
wird die farbe hinkommen ich werde
dieses gebäude hier ziemlich krass
umbauen das wird sehr sehr geil aussehen
ich werde auch das hier ein bisschen
umbauen allerdings würde ich
ja ich geschlafen und besorgt alle
sachen die wir für die willicher insel
2.0 benötigen oh
[Musik]
mein gott
15 minuten war ich gerade unterwegs und
habe mit diese ganzen sachen die
zusammen betrachtet dass sie zwar nicht
so viele aus ist ist allerdings extrem
viel und es hat so lange gedauert von
daher kann ich euch jetzt endlich zeigen
wo wir das neue ausbauen werden das
kommt nämlich hier vorne hin
dementsprechend mache ich ganz gut da
eben noch mal das ganze gras weg und wir
setzen das so hin dass wir hier ein zwei
dazwischen frei haben also hier eine
treppe hin die kommen jetzt hier so
und
es ist auch noch nicht fertig die hier
war nur so provisorisch erstmal
allerdings soll das ganze haus hier
vorne aussehen wie
das ganze haus hier soll ein bisschen
aussehen wie ein fass habe ich mir
gedacht und dementsprechend soll das
auch von der seite so aussehen als wird
das so ein bisschen so hier in der luft
schweben das hier vorne ist der eingang
dann kommt man hier quasi so hoch hier
vorne machen wir 123 fichtenholz spengel
hinein 23 denn hier
1234 platz und hier vorne kannst dann
auch schon wieder rum gehen dass wir
keine riesiges haus allerdings kommen
dort vier betten rein so dass wir
endlich mal ein bisschen platz haben
so dass er endlich mal ein bisschen
platz haben so dass sich diese ganzen
leute hier so ein bisschen zur ruhe
kommen lassen können tun und auch ein
bisschen kuscheln können alle
miteinander hier vorne kommen die teile
so hin die habe ich jetzt mal wieder
falsch gesetzt ich stehe total neben der
spur ich bin schon bei eineinhalb
stunden und wir sind in der folge
wahrscheinlich gerade erst mal bei
irgendwie fünf minuten oder so weil ich
schon so viele timeless gemacht habe um
die ganzen sachen zusammen zu sammeln
allerdings wehte schon ich habe wirklich
eine menge fichtenholz holen müssen weil
das hier sind diese stimme dafür habe
ich mir auch die galt es ist noch nicht
fertig
[Musik]
dann wohnst du halt woanders so hier
vorne kommen die stämme auch noch hin
und hier kommen dann auch fenster rein
dafür habe ich extra schwarze
glasscheiben genommen weil ich die
tatsächlich ein bisschen schöner finde
mittlerweile als die normalen
glasscheiben weil die so ein bisschen
getönt hat sind das habe ich hinter der
villa so ein bisschen lieben gelernt und
hier vorne den boden mache ich auch
nicht bis zum boden hin sondern das ist
alles ein bisschen in der luft schweben
genauso wie von außen so dass sich das
in so ein bisschen wieder findet hier
vorne platzieren wird zac und zack eine
treppe hin und hier zack zack das ist
falsch und sagte die hier bei euch mal
ganz kurz wieder ab und setzt sie auch
so hin denn hier zwischen soll nun eine
fichtenholz tür rein und auch noch
fichtenholz falltüren hier von der seite
die sollen nämlich die so und so dass
das ganze haus von außen so aussieht
perfekt das dach des hauses hier vorne
soll wie folgt aussehen und zwar habe
ich mir dafür hier schon züchten
holztreppen gemacht die kommen jetzt
nämlich zack und sagt hier das ist
falsch
mach das mal doch lieber von ihr ausgeht
glaube ich ein bisschen einfacher die
sollen nämlich einmal so hier rum gehen
hier ist jetzt der komposter natürlich
im weg und sagte ja auch noch mal drum
herum das ist einfach beziehungsweise
hat einfach den grund weil ich da dann
so ein bisschen das dach habe genauso
wie hier vorne mit den fichten
holztreppen untätig abi nicht den zug
dom
nicht antworten
das kann sich nicht ausdenken ich wollte
halt wirklich früher mal architektur
studieren alter ich bin
so und so die letzte treppe hier vorne
jetzt nehmen wir unsere laternen und
machen erstmal ein bisschen beleuchtung
dran das soll nämlich so ein bisschen
außen habe ich mich so ein bisschen an
so weiß nicht bei uns zu hause in
bielefeld gibt es ein asiatisches
restaurant die haben auch an jeder ecke
sondern gerne hängen das nicht
eigentlich mal ganz schön ich finde man
kann von licht hin nie genug haben in
minecraft hier drinnen sind noch nicht
so schön dass ich mir auch ganz normal
provisorische treppe hoch dass hier
vorne kann ich auch noch mal eben
abbauen und hier kommt jetzt das dach
drauf habe platzieren wir hier außenrum
erstmal ganz normale fichtenholz bretter
zack und zack und hier nun die fichten
holzstufen damit dass alles noch ein
bisschen luftiger wirkt hier vorne die
reihe zu ende hier die reihe zu ende und
hier vorne auch noch 1 2 3 4 5 6 und
hier vorne drauf auch noch mal ein 23 12
13 2 das war falsch zack zack und hannah
mittag 12 dann können wir das ganze mal
eben wieder abbauen dass sie wird das
dach auf jeden fall sein und von drinnen
sieht das ganze jetzt gerade noch so aus
da nehmen wir mal ganz kurz mal eben die
erde hier wieder weg das sieht echt geil
auf mit den schwarzen glasscheiben finde
ich weil das außen alles ein bisschen
getönt ist allerdings nehmen wir hierfür
jetzt auch unsere fichtenholz treppen
platzieren die so und so das gute ist
dass wir jetzt hier diese kleine
ja diese kleine lücke haben wo wir doch
noch mal zwei laternen platzieren könnte
mich hier vorne und da haben wir ein
bisschen licht hier drin und ihr seht
schon ich habe hier eine menge betten
gemacht sind denn das hier soll so ein
bisschen eine kleine jugendherberge
werden also hier sollen die alle
schlafen können und sich dann quasi mehr
hinlegen und
dann halt einfach dass sie wissen dass
sie hier leben und nicht da hinten in
meinem baumhaus zu wie der andere typ
der da oben die ganze zeit rum läuft und
was ich mir auch noch gemacht habe ist
ein schmelzofen und ein schleifstein die
werde ich nämlich hier vorne hinsetzen
einmal hier und einmal noch ihr drauf so
dass irgendjemand dem wir ja hier vorne
im brötchen haben vielleicht am besten
der hier sogar dass der den beruf dort
vorne annimmt und dementsprechend
rüstung und auch diamant gegenstände
waffen etc handeln kann gegen zudem
haben viele smaragde haben allerdings
noch gar nicht so richtig angefangen mit
dem trading von daher lasse ich ihn
jetzt erstmal hier raus hier direkt mein
brötchen mit und hoffe dass er jetzt
hier vorne hingeht und sich dort einen
beruf snackt
daumen drücken er ist oben er sieht das
häuschen er geht rein
wir haben es geschafft leute und wisst
ihr was wir jetzt auch machen können wir
können unser brot nehmen und das
aufteilen die schmerzen 48 brot
wer will das nicht
das tut mir auch unten in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich gar nicht 30 brote
hinschmeißen soll sondern jeder braucht
einfach acht stück kommen er hat die auf
gesammelt um in schmeiße ich auch
nochmal acht bekennen er sammelt ja auch
auf das heißt die beiden müssten sich
jetzt wohl das schwert nach oben das ist
schon brutal
beiden müssten sich doch jetzt warum
macht ihr nichts
ja da habe ich aber keine zeit für heute
unter meiner letzten folge haben
übrigens auch ganz ganz viele leute in
die kommentare geschrieben und dafür
wollte ich mich auch ganz kurz mal
bedanken dass das eigentlich gar nicht
so schlimm da mit meiner lippe und das
ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch im schnitt
nachher aufgefallen also ich hab dann
riesig großen hier raus gemacht und
dachte halt irgendwie das geht gar nicht
klar mit meiner lippe es tut mir leid
ich muss meinen mund zensieren uns
weiter und so fort allerdings war es
schlussendlich gar nicht mal so schlimm
und ich habe mich dann auch so ein
bisschen blöd gefühl dass ich das so oft
im video erwähnt habe aber es sahel zone
die kamera an zu haben wirklich
schlimmer aus als dann schlussendlich im
video aber danke auf jeden fall für eure
ganzen genesungswünsche unter dem
letzten video und auch danke für euer
riesiges feedback unter dem letzten
video das hat mich wirklich sehr gefreut
wir waren einfach in den deutschen
youtube trends auf dem verdammten ersten
platz vor irgendwelchen rappern die ihre
monatelange musik rausgebracht haben
dann und so weiter und so fort ich habe
mich da wirklich schlecht gefühlt dass
wir mit so einer ganz normalen minecraft
situation hier plötzlich in den main in
den youtube trends sind wir waren das
angesagteste video in deutschland an dem
tag und das habe ich wirklich dass es
unfassbar da wollte ich mich einfach mal
für euren riesigen support bedanken
freuen ich habe hier vorne gar keine
werkbank ist mir gerade aufgefallen ich
brauche allerdings eine werkbank um mir
noch ein bisschen fichtenholz falten zu
machen dass abdi garad schon gesehen ich
habe dort nämlich meine farben gerade
schon mal so ein bisschen angefangen das
heißt hier vorne mal ganz kurz ebenfalls
war 34 mehr brauche ich sogar
tatsächlich auch noch so setzte sagt 16
stück 20 stück sollten auf jeden fall
reichen und die hacke muss sich auch
mitnehmen zack und die kerne habe ich
glaube ich nebenan alle auf der insel
denn ich möchte die ganze verein schon
gesagt so ein bisschen höher setzen und
dafür möchte ich die so ein bisschen
abtrennen und dafür habe ich mir diese
fichtenholz fall turnier gemacht zack
zack zack zack alle die neu sind beim
projekt werde sich wahrscheinlich denken
hill luca war machst alles verzichten
häufig liebe fichtenholz einfach ich
finde fichtenholz ist das schönste
material in minecraft dass man irgendwie
benutzen kann hier vorne soll es
allerdings nicht sein den wir mal ganz
kurz weg und hier an der seite bauen wir
auch noch mal eben kurz den bambus ab
der bambus soll nämlich nur hier vorne
links bei dem aktien baum so ein
bisschen wachsen weil er mir doch ein
bisschen zu groß wurde den wirklich kann
ich noch mal ein bisschen weiter bauen
die ganze insel wird ja also ein
dauerprojekt auch seien die soll sich
immer weiter erweitern so dass wir
schlussendlich irgendwann hier unsere
komplette eigene insel haben unser
eigenes dorf was wir uns selbst ein
bisschen quasi aufgebaut haben und hier
kommt dann quasi erst mal die farm hin
wo ich das ganze jetzt auch wie folgt
anordnen werde ich freue mich so
unfassbar dollar bei der heutigen
episode meine lieben freunde die kann
wirklich 101 in meiner lieblings folgen
in das projekt minecraft mit luca bisher
allerdings die bereits ich habe hier
vorne mir da gedacht dass ich hier
zweimal eine filmreihe mit weizen hin
mache dann hier einen melonen kehren und
dann habe ich ja auch noch einen
kürbiskern hier vorne so dass wir hier
dann immer so eine melone stehen haben
und hier so einen kürbis und hier auf
die seite habe ich mir gedacht dass ich
dort kartoffeln anpflanzen komplett also
hier komplett kartoffeln hier komplett
weizen und hier melonen und kürbisse die
sache ist allerdings dass ich fast keine
kartoffeln mehr hatte deswegen werde ich
mal ganz kurz hier so ein bisschen das
alles so ein bisschen spritzen hiermit
mit einem knochenmehl dass ihr hiervon
ein paar mehr haben zack zack zack zack
den kartoffeln ist wirklich ein
hauptnahrungsmittel in minecraft die
ganzen anderen sachen packe ich mal hier
rein und auch ein bisschen knochenmehl
die kartoffeln behalte ich rote beete
habe ich jetzt nicht angepflanzt weil
ich die ganze zeit nicht so richtig
wusste wofür ich über brauche was ich
damit machen kann ich glaube zum trading
ist die ganz gut aber so sollte das erst
mal reichen also das hier ist unsere
neue fan ich werde hier vorne auch noch
fackel die sonne geht schon wieder unter
ich
sage euch am ende wie lange ich
aufgenommen habe aber das ist nicht mehr
feierlich gerade
so ich hab euch gerade noch mal ganz
kurz detail apps eingeblendet denn ich
habe mir gerade die sachen geholt die
ich für meine neuen brünnen oder buch
runden ist dass die mehrzahl ich weiß es
nicht auf jeden fall benötige denn ich
vermisse ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen
in brunnen und unsere semi automatische
fahren die wir da hinten haben ich finde
ihn sehr deutlich schöner weil wir
wirklich nicht so viel essen benötigen
wir dort immer uns angepflanzt hat und
wir wollen noch ein bisschen nachhaltig
leben allerdings vermisse ich den boden
so ein bisschen nicht an denen ich ganz
schön den hype pixel da gebaut hatte da
hab ich mich also ein bisschen daran
orientiert und den ganzen möchte ich
jetzt auch noch mal hierhin bauen einmal
hier zack und auch noch mal ich mach
doch gerade das ist ja alles wieder zu
gras wurde das auch sehr schnell
gegangen sehr geil und ich möchte den
gleichen boden auch nochmal hier vorne
hin bauen denn ich finde ein brunnen
kann nicht schaden aber zwei brunnen
können noch viel weniger schaden und wir
hatten ja auch damals in den brunnen
einen schleifstein drin der eigentlich
eher dekorative elemente mit sich
brachte die sache ist allerdings dass
wenn wir neue wille german und dann der
sich eventuell auf den schleifstein
konzentriert das wäre dementsprechend
dem beruf bekommt und dem anderen
brunnen werde ich auch keinen
schleifstein reinsetzen sondern die
glocke das können dann auch mal testen
ihr seht auch schon gerade ich weiß
immer noch ganz genau wie sie wohnen
funktionieren damit eines der ersten
ästhetischen design projekte die ich in
diesem minecraft projekte generell hatte
hier vorne die
wir fordern die schein ziegelmauern
darauf und die hier vorne auch also ich
baue jetzt quasi zweimal einfach
komplett das gleiche auf die steinige
mauern kommen dann hier diese
fichtenholz zeile darauf und hier vorne
auf sagt sack und pack und da drauf
jetzt 14 dichten holztreppen auch noch
mal ganz schnell dann muss ich mich hier
an der seite eben einmal ganz kurz hoch
bauen
[Musik]
und auf der anderen seite hier vorne
auch noch mal eben leute ich bin
wirklich unfassbar wie kriegt das hin
allerdings müssen wir als einmal ganz
kurz durch und nachher wird auf jeden
fall richtig geil aussehen also die
treppen hier sind fertig die hier vorne
kann ich abbauen und dazwischen kommen
nun sich den holzstufen nämlich zack
zack zack hier noch eine und darauf auch
noch mal eben kurz welche nämlich einmal
kurz hier über gesamt sack und pack und
wir vorne auch noch mal eine pflicht
neue stufe hin die habe ich mir gerade
mal eben noch mal neu gecastet hier
vorne hängen wir jetzt den schleifstein
daran und an dem schleifstein montag die
kettengliedern hier unten rein gehen
jetzt fehlt nur noch das wasser das habe
ich mir schon einen eimer mitgenommen es
können jetzt einfach ihr nehmen und hier
rein platzieren und dann den zweiten
aber was da noch verein und auch den
dritten auch damit den ersten
bodenschatz
der erste brunnen ist jetzt auf jeden
fall fertig genau das gleiche werden wir
jetzt auch noch auf der anderen seite
bauen das heißt ich baue ich auch eben
einmal ganz kurz hoch nehmen meine
fichtenholz treppen setzte die hierhin
dann hier an die seite müssen wir uns
einmal kurz die so ein bisschen jackie
chan mäßig an der seite her bauens
man merkte ich nehme mehr als zwei
stunden auf ich glaube dass man das im
video immer nie so richtig mitbekommen
wie lange ich wirklich aufnehmen weil
voll häufig sehe ich auch kommentare von
leuten die da so schreiben die kasseler
schon aufnehmen das video geht doch nur
20 minuten ja ich weiss allerdings
arbeite ich ja viel metall bleibt es und
schneider auch immer ganz viel einige
werden immer vor luca wird er schneidet
unterschiede der uns so aber ich
verstehe dass immer nie so richtig so
was soll s mir selbst einbringen wenn
man schüttet ich glaube jeder der
irgendwie mal gta oder irgendwelche
spiele gespielt hat wo es wirklich um
das tor ging also klar bei minecraft
geht jetzt nicht um eine richtige story
aber das spiel wird ganz ganz schnell
langweilig wenn man sich jetzt selbst
kaputt macht dadurch dass man steht
deswegen würde ich so was halt einfach
nie machen und möchte einfach den spaß
aus dem hinteren aufrechterhalten und
wir haben ja auch keinen zeitdruck also
ob ich jetzt keine ahnung das video ein
bisschen länger aufnehme oder mir
irgendwie dazwischen dann irgendwas
mache was ich eh nicht machen werde dann
das macht aber keinen sinn was ich kann
alles sage ihr wisst aber durch was ich
meinem ich werde mich jetzt allerdings
hier so ein bisschen anders
konzentrieren bei der ganzen sache denn
eigentlich kommt er jetzt hier eine
fichtenholz stufe dran und dann darunter
auch sonst stand und die kette da habe
ich mir allerdings gedacht dass wir die
glocke ja cool integrieren müssen von
daher einfach eine kette und da die
glocke dran hier die stufe nehme ich mir
mal eben und auch meinen wassereimer
beziehungsweise meinen normalen heimat
und fülle dort leben ganz kurz wasser
rein so dass wir das auch hier vorne
haben
[Musik]
was hab ich
gibt
jetzt funktioniert es auf jeden fall
also ich habe
[Musik]
dieser trend nicht da die sonne
allerdings schon wieder untergeht würde
ich sagen geben
die haben zwei kinder na gut morgen war
ein kleiner ausflug in der
jugendherberge ist klappt auf jeden fall
richtig richtig gut mit den betten hier
und das freut mich extrem die ganzen
stehen auf und sind wach wie es kommt
auf jeden fall leben hier rein wie vor
niemand drin geschlafen mir hier nicht
hat hier jemand drin geschlafen hat er
darin geschlafen als wir haben 1 2
erwachsene und 2 kinder die hier oben
spielen kommen hier könnt euch bisher de
perfekt ich weiß nicht was ich hier
falsch gebaut habe ich baue das man
einmal ganz kurz noch mal eben hier
abzocke und auch hier vorne mal eben
kurz die fichtenholz stufe abbauen und
hier die erde hin ich weiß nicht was ich
irgendwie falsch gemacht habe das
ach so ich habe glaube ich in die stufe
wasser eingesetzt das hatte ich glaube
ich auch bei meinem ersten brunnen den
ich damals gebaut hatte dass sich das
wasser falsch anvisiert hatte oder
irgendwie so also ich muss wirklich auf
dem boden das ganze richten dienstag
sack und pack dann sollte das ganze
funktionieren dann sehen jetzt auch
schon dass wir diesen brunnen fertig
haben und diesen brunnen hier können wir
jetzt am schleifstein bisschen was
reparieren und entzaubern damit kenne
ich mich noch nicht so richtig aus das
tipps habt schreibt gerne und in die
kommentare aber hier haben jetzt das
hier machen
ihr seht schon jeder geht rein in sein
haus und das hört auch er da oben also
erst erledigt seinem einem baumhaus drin
aber jeder weiß dann quasi er es kommt
irgendwie war es keine ahnung was pipapo
und deswegen dachte ich dass das
vielleicht ganz gut wenn wir hier an die
glocke habe und ihr den schleifstein
dann ist das hier so ein bisschen so der
boden und das ist dann so der
mittelpunkt und keine ahnung was genau
die laternen wäre ich ganz kurz mal hier
vorne dran hängen denn das pflanzen
beziehung
hier sollen keine kartoffeln oder rote
beete war daher sollte die melone
wachsen das erwächst natürlich deutlich
schneller wenn hier nicht so richtig
dran kommt deswegen habe hier so eine
menge nicht wir haben hier liegt hier
bei den brunnen brauchen jetzt glaube
ich nicht ich werde mir allerdings
generell mal meine stein ziegelmauern
nehmen und hier einfach mal überall noch
so ein bisschen laternen hinsetzen so
dass wir ein bisschen mehr beleuchtung
haben wir haben hier zwar auf der insel
hier vorne schon da sollst du nicht hin
wir haben auf der insel hier vorne 2
schuy 2.0 der ja so ein bisschen
aufpasst allerdings kann nicht trotzdem
nicht schaden hier vorne das sollte
eigentlich genug sein glaube ich hier
vorn um die ecke rum hier können wir mal
einen eben hinsetzen und vielleicht noch
mal hier vorne irgendwie auf ecke so
hier
das nicht kommen lassen dass ich glaube
das sollte auf jeden fall reichen mit
der beleuchtung vielleicht hier vorne
noch so ein bisschen hier oder so und
dann geht hier der fliegt damit war sie
irgendwann mal weiter das habe ich auch
so ein bisschen angedeutet dass es auf
jeden fall noch weiter gehen soll mit
der insel allerdings haben wir wirklich
schon eine menge geschafft ich werde
jetzt mal ganz kurz bommel holen das
hier ein bisschen auf dem boden packen
[Musik]
so dass das hier vorne auch alles so ein
bisschen verbuchte aussieht und
dementsprechend alles so ein bisschen
zum rest von unserer ganzen welt passt
hier vorne auch noch mal so ein bisschen
rum das recht müssen zu verbuchen aber
hier vorne dann so ein bisschen hier um
die ecke noch mal drauf klicken und hier
so ein bisschen dann sieht alles ein
bisschen schöner aussieht findet immer
ganz geil wenn das alles so ein bisschen
mit dem gras hier voll gewachsen ist
hier vorne um die ecke auch noch und was
ich noch machen wollten dafür seht ihr
schon unten ich hab mir wieder ein
lagerfeuer abgebaut einzige morgen
reisen falsche und ein schmelzofen denn
das haus hier vorne das ist ja auch
irgendwie noch nicht so das wahre und da
habe ich mir jetzt gedacht dass ich das
hier vorne einfach mal abbauen und werde
da haben wir hier das lagerfeuer und da
werde ich auch generell einfach mal da
habe ich ja gar nicht verstehen warum
ich das hier oben überhaupt aus diesem
holz gemacht habe weil das hier soll so
ein bisschen ja unsere stein hütte
werden deswegen werde ich erst mal diese
eichenholz stufen wir abbauen hier vorne
und auch den boden abbauen und jetzt
kommt die jedes jahr 1000 denn ich
möchte ich hier ein lagerfeuer hinsetzen
darüber den schmelzofen so dass der so
ein bisschen hochgeht und dann möchte
ich darüber allerdings eine eisen
falsche sätze und eine stein ziegelmauer
also das ist wirklich so ein bisschen
wie so ein ofen aussieht wie hinten
unserer modernen strandhaus villa also
das sieht wirklich sehr offen mit so
einer abzugshaube und hier oben kommt
dass dann sogar raus denn hier oben
haben wir ja noch ein lagerfeuer hin
platziert da habe ich mir allerdings
gedacht dass ich das hier nicht so schön
finde mit diesem ding das man das halt
sieht deswegen möchte ich hier vorne auf
jeden fall dieser stein zuge
mauersteinen maucksch bruchsteinmauer
abbauen und nicht eine buchstein stufe
ersetzen das sieht glaube ich ein
bisschen schöner aus von außen ich hab's
mir bisher nur ein attest welt angeguckt
aber ich glaube dass es auch hier ganz
gut aussehen könnte weil man es nicht so
richtig wahrnimmt man denkt die hilfe
kommt ende der raucher und dann geht man
rein und die a-ha die ist noch offen das
tier vorne möchte ich dann so ein
bisschen vollmachten mit bruchsteinen
stufen und hier an die seite habe ich
mir gedacht da kommt keine laterne hin
sondern eine fackel weil ich finde eine
fackel passt irgendwie besser wenn ich
glaube ich sogar so hin ich finde fackel
passt besser zusammen haus wenn das so
alles steinig ist und so ein bisschen
ich weiß es nicht ich komme immer gerne
und in die kommentare schreiben was ihr
davon haltet das sie haben jetzt quasi
so ein bisschen neu gemacht ich habe mir
auch eine neue bruchsteinmauern gemacht
wie möchte ich ihn nämlich auch komplett
hochziehen ich glaube das nicht ein
bisschen schöner aus wenn das dann
einmal so komplette umgeht und
dementsprechend so ein bisschen so einen
runderen charakter hat das ganze haus
und
das war es glaube ich ich habe jetzt
insgesamt zum allerersten mal
zwei stunden und 37 minuten aufgenommen
wenn euch meine lieben freunde das
heutige video gefallen hat dann würde
ich mich unfassbar dollar bei einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video
hier freund schreibt mit unten in die
kommentare ob ich hier eine brücke hin
bauen soll oder ob es bei diesen
rosenblättern bleiben soll und wenn ihr
ja sagt also wenn alle schreiben ja da
sollen eine brücke hin lukas ich weiß
nicht ich kann mir das noch nicht so
richtig vorstellen aber wir können immer
gucken und wenn die da bock drauf habe
dann werde ich mich da staunen machen
und mir da ein paar designs raussuchen
wenn ich das machen soll also wenn ich
da eine brücke hin wollen soll soll das
dann übermorgen stattfinden in der neuen
folge minecraft mit butter oder sollen
wir übermorgen eine neue erkundungstour
machen und mal dort hinten fahren da
hinten befindet sicher dass hills biom
und wir sind noch nie weiter als das psb
umgegangen also was soll ich in der
übernächsten folge wer in der nächsten
folge machen übermorgen soll ich eine
brücke bauen wenn er da überhaupt bock
drauf habt oder solch eine
erkundungstour machen allerdings haben
wir hier wirklich heute extrem viel
geschafft die billiger sind schon
erwachsen die haben verschiedene berufe
der mit eine rüstung schmid wir haben
einen waffenschmied wir haben hier den
bauer
ja die pflanzen sich schon wieder weiter
fort wir haben hier noch die kriegen
schon wieder ein klein ich bin unfassbar
happy es war bisher wirklich meine
lieblings folge des kompletten projekt
weil ich das einfach liebe wenn man
sachen cool kreativ umsetzen kann wir
haben hier den neuen brunnen mit dem
schleifstein dann wir haben ja einen
brunnen mit einer glocke läuten dann
gehen alle reihen in ihre häuser wir
haben die farben schöner gebaut wir
haben überall beleuchtung wir haben hier
zwei anstatt der aufpasst erstes
wirklich wahnsinnig geil geworden die
heutige episode es tut mir leid dass ich
noch immer nicht so richtig lachen kann
wegen meiner lippe allerdings meine
lieben freunde wie bereits gesagt lass
gerne einen daumen hoch und ein video
der abonniert main kanal als auch keinen
der lose seiten klicken auf die glocke
um die nächste folge über morgen um 20
uhr nicht zu verpassen ich habe mich
liebte sie
[Musik]